good morning and good evening uh
everybody depending upon what time zone
you are in as chip rightly said that
we're going to be discussing quite a lot
about the topic which is related to
minting money with your blogging skills
using AdSense so uh before I go ahead
and begin I'm assuming that
most of you are already aware about what
AdSense is but uh just to keep it on the
same page we would definitely go ahead
and talk about the basics of AdSense and
then we'll get on to the integrities of
what all skill sets what all the dos and
what are the don'ts uh when it comes
down to making money to the whever you
have any questions like uh uh it's been
mention you can go ahead and type that
across we'll have a question and
answer uh discussion at the end uh which
is going to be like after 45 to 50
minutes all
right so as my introduction has already
been done so I'm just going to run
across through the slide I'm a digital
marketing Enthusiast and it's been more
than 18 years I've been into this
profession you name any uh particular
certification into the digital marketing
industry guys I'm I've uh made myself
eligible for all of those I also I'm I'm
also running across my own internet
marketing agency which is bed out of
Toronto Canada and we do get across to
several small medium and uh vune 500
organizations in terms meeting their
internet marketing needs I'm also a
speaker and speaker at several business
schools and colleges and universities
based in Canada and India some of those
being University of Toronto humble
College Toronto I am bangaluru I am Amad
I kpur and several others so I speak on
digital marketing at several places like
these several universities and colleges
in case you want to know more about me
in detail you can refer to my LinkedIn
profile just go to linkedin.com and type
in my name which is
nickm all right so what is AdSense if
you try to understand the basics of
AdSense guys most of you would be
already knowing about uh this particular
piece of product which Google offers
across uh that is primarily used across
by Publishers for making money so what
exactly it is how does it work and how
do you make money let's get uh start on
knowing more about it so AdSense is one
of the product which Google
has offered across to Publishers
Publishers as in those people who have
got their own blogs own websites they
create content and with the help of
content which they are creating and
uploading across on of their platforms
they have the desire to make some money
out of it to earn to remunerate that
content and how they will go ahead and
do that these Publishers they go ahead
and subscribe themselves to Google
AdSense which is by just going ahead on
and type across google.com/ AdSense you
will get across so if you are a blogger
or a website owner or a publisher you
need to go ahead and sign in to Google
AdSense with your existing Google
account given across all the details to
Google which it's going to ask for with
which is very basic information your
address your PIN code your age your
phone number your website details your
first name and last name and your age
and so forth the very first and foremost
thing you need to be a years and above
in order to use a cross adson so that is
something which is there plus you need
to have a website which is six months at
least old so you cannot apply for
AdSense until unless you do not have a
website which is not 6 months old so
what you can see over here in this
picture it's a website or a Blog where
they're on the blue color boxes which
you're seeing that's where
the that's the space where the
Publishers are actually offering a cross
to AdSense or Google you can say so
Google AdSense and Google ultimately
will sell that space to
advertisers so how do these Publishers
really make money once they have got a
banner ad or any text ad onto their
websites they get paid Whenever there is
a visitor on their website and the
visitor clicks onto the ad either it's
on the payperclick basis or it's on the
impression basis so that's CPM that
stand for cost per thousand Impressions
so for every thousand times the ad is
being viewed or shown across there's a
particular
price which is not standard which
differs across which is dynamic which
differs across from situation to
situation and the kind of uh money which
The Advertiser is spending
across now how does this entire
mechanism work if you try to look into
the overall ecosystem of Google AdSense
this is where Publishers are on the
extreme left and then you have have on
the extreme right the advertisers so how
it all start and and in the middle in in
in between the server right which is the
Display Network precisely now the
advertisers go ahead and approach across
Google through Google AdWords Google
AdWords is another product which Google
offers across to advertisers to create
across advertisements whether it's a
text ad or an image ad or a video ad
whatever different kind of an
advertisement is the advertisers go
ahead and approach Google with the help
of Google AdWords create Those ads get
the targeting option on the overall
targeting options which are available
and those particular advertisements are
being served across onto the Google ad
server Google ad server does the major
work where it manages the entire
inventory of various
Publishers right it gives Publishers the
access to the large pool of advertisers
and vice versa advertisers are able to
go ahead and select across various
publisher websites and Publishers are
also getting across a large pool of
advertisers ultimately Google which is
standing in between which is contacting
Publishers on one side through Google
AdSense and contacting advertisers for
Google AdWords they're doing their own
uh Google is doing its own work and
they're charging a particular cut on
whatever money advertisers pay on every
click or every thousand impressions so
let's say for an example there is an x
amount which The Advertiser is paying
whenever there's a viewer or a visitor
coming onto the website and then clicks
onto the ad a visitor when comes onto
the website and clicks on an ad let's
say there is $1 which The Advertiser is
paying from their pocket the percentage
is not known how much percentage of that
$1 is going to be kept across with
Google and how much will it get
transferred to Publishers Google doesn't
go ahead and say that in public how much
percentage would that be but it's
been uh it's it's actually heard that
it's 60% which Google keeps it with
thems which is 60 cents out of $1 which
is being SP spent so advertisers is
paying $1 pun so I'm just taking an
example $1 per click 60 cents stays with
Google and 40 remaining cents is being
transferred across to the publisher
publisher is getting remunerated for the
hard work which they're doing now these
Publishers are able to get across the
that money because of Google
AdSense all right now the type of
advertisements since we are working we
are just talking about the basics of
AdSense right now it's uh very important
to go ahead and understand the overall
process and overall understand the
various different type of ads which
AdSense
allows so the different type of ads ads
are the banner ads the text dis the text
ads the display ads on mobile it's a
banner ad in the text and display and if
you talk about on the search it's the
custom search function the video ads and
so forth which are the interactive media
ads now how does AdSense really helps
the
Publishers that's where we have to
really get into and understand we as
Publishers what can we really do in
order to go ahead and increase our
Revenue make much much more money then
to what we are doing right now what are
the dos and the don'ts we'll get on to
that once we are done with the basics
now AdSense helps Publishers to access
first of all we spoke about large pool
of advertisers who approach Google with
the help of Google AdWords as one of the
product without making sure that they
have to so Publishers do not have to get
into the entire ball game of contacting
different advertisers one after another
after another so it's just one point of
contact which is getting easy for both
the advertisers and Publishers so
Publishers do not have to contact
multiple advertisers and one Advertiser
do not have to contact multiple
Publishers both ways it's Google which
actually does the entire job by taking
care of the Google Display Network it's
a large pool of advertisers which
ultimately helps in bringing in a lot of
higher competition and this competition
is healthy it translates into much
better relevant ads ultimately it's the
viewer or the visitor who's getting much
better value out of it it does provide
flexible ad controls also which is uh
which is the AdSense so we as Publishers
can go ahead and control what kind of
advertisements can come on our website
and what kind of advertisements can
really
be ignored or can be stopped or strict
or ban or so forth we can we as
publisher can even Define what sort of
size and what's what different size of
banner ads or text ads can come or video
ads plus also we can we have Publishers
can Define the frequency as well there
is analytics in into the Google AdSense
which does gives an overall detailed
report on what different advertisments
have performed which all different pages
have performed on what particular day
and so forth what are the different
factors which affect the revenues well
it's the amount of traffic which you're
getting the volume it's a source of
traffic whether the traffic is majorly
coming on your website from search
engines or from the social media sites
or and so forth the different so from
different countries the topic the
content which is there on the website
overall quality of ads and also the
click through rate now if we talk about
the difference between these two
products which Google offers which is
AdSense and AdWords how they're
different I've already spoken about it
AdSense is for Publishers and AdWords is
for the
advertisers right and in between it's
Google which is taking care of both the
ends taking care of advertisers pool and
taking care of the publisher pool right
so Google AdWords is primarily for the
business owners and uh it is used by the
business owners to go ahead and create
across advertisements of whatever type
they want whether it's to be put in
across the text ads on search Network or
to be put in across video ads on YouTube
Network or on the Display Network or
display ads which come comprises of the
text ads or the banner
ads onto the Display Network and so
forth so advertisers are using Google
AdWords by paying across to Google on
CPC and CPM model both in order to go
ahead and get across relevant targeted
traffic onto their website and get
across the conversions the end results
which they're looking for conversions
can be of any kind as we all know that
either it uh for a campaign a conversion
could could be a newsletter subscription
or it could be a sale onto a website or
it could be a form fill up and so forth
now if you go further on to
understanding Google AdSense that's the
other side of the story where the
Publishers are going ahead and getting
them themselves registered on Google
AdSense so that they can monetize a
specific platform which is free and uh
it is primarily meant to get across
Revenue out of the
total the overall entire traffic which
is coming on the website it is primarily
for monetizing that traffic now since uh
we are talking about how do we really go
ahead and mint more money with our with
our blog with our blogging skills
through AdSense we have understood one
side which is AdSense we have understood
the overall Dynamics behind how Google
AdSense and Google AdWords really come
into the picture now let's talk more on
blogs and what all different skill sets
are logger really needs to have in order
to increase their revenue and meant much
more money so if we try to understand
what exactly a Blog is it's purely a
personal Journal an online personal
Journal which people go ahead and write
across just like a personal diary right
which is used across for sharing
information for uh giving across
opinions for writing across certain
reviews and so forth block could be a
various kinds right whether it can can
be just image related stuff blog can be
uh related to just having videos you can
have different medium of content onto
blogs it's just a medium of
communication which is also used across
for Revenue generation purposes if
you're blogging effectively which is
only done if you have
got Google AdSense uh Google AdSense
upload connected across with your blog
now the different type of blogs if we
talk about are the personal blogs
corporate and the media blogs I mean
there could be several more dis sections
of blogs but this is on the most
uh basic level if we talk about right so
for all the different kind of blogs
Google AdSense can be used there's no
restriction in terms of Google AdSense
that only such kind of blogs would be uh
giving across permission and so forth
any sort of a Blog can get across Google
AdSense approval why you should really
go ahead and start across blogging well
uh if you are fond of something you are
you like doing something and you want to
share across information about that then
that is the right time to go ahead and
blog about it you should not keep in
mind that you're doing blogging just to
making just to make money it has to be
the other way around if you're
passionate about something you love
something and you can just go on and on
and uh share as much information as much
experience you've got about something
which is purely unique which is not
shared on any other resource then
half of your job is done in terms of
minting more money this is one thumb
rule when you are looking at minting
more money through Adin just find out
that single thing which uh which excites
you the most which you're passionate
about the most if you can go ahead and
find that thing and then start writing
and sharing across that stuff in the
most appropriate fashion the most
effective fashion there are certain
other marketing skills which has to be
added onto it first of all the content
has to be which is uh which is
purely coming in from the Fest mouth you
can say uh which is not being shared
across some from on any other platform
it's Unique and uh when you share across
that sort of information you are
easily attracting more money towards
your Google AdSense account ultimately
it's going to be more traffic people are
going to like your stuff because
ultimately you're more passionate about
that and uh The credibility has to
really get into uh built and that would
have to be coupled across with the all
the digital marketing uh skill sets
whether it's to do with search engine
optimization how to optimize a website
for the search engines or whether to do
with getting more traffic with the help
of email marketing and so forth and so
on right so if you are passionate about
something then you start blogging across
whether it's for your personal blog or
whether it's related to a corporate blog
if a
company is also Pro uh looking for some
more promotion with whatever product and
services you're selling across and your
organization is also the key master in
the product and services they're selling
across and you have people who are great
experience in that sort of product and
Services I mean just make them make them
right which would really attract the
target audience so make sure you are
writing to go ahead
and uh give across a treat to the End
customer right this is the best way to
share across Ross knowledge which is the
blog and to also pursue across your
hobby or your profession like I said and
one of the best ways to make money and
it's it's cheap right so how do you
really get started if we talk again
about the basics before we get into the
overall dos and don'ts and uh much much
more pointers through which you will be
able to make much more money in the
basics when when we talk about a blogger
once he or she has decided what exactly
they're passionate about and what topic
would they really be would they love to
go ahead and talk about the next thing
is to really go ahead and ask yourself
on which platform would you do that
there are many more other questions
which are coupled up with uh what you
want to write about whether it's going
to
be uh whether the other question is can
you be consistent uh do you have an
opinion on certain topic uh and you
cannot really write on that for uh good
amount of uh weeks and good amount of
months and so for so you have to really
consider all that excuse
me right so will and you need to also
ask yourself other questions will others
which is your end audience would they be
interested in Reading what you're going
to be liking so there has to be a lot of
experimentation which will go initially
as well like I said once you have
identified all that then in from the
basics point of view it's all about
identifying the best platform for
blogging there are various platforms
which are available across it when it
comes down to identifying that platform
which will help you to make much more
money or much more uh well there is no
answer to that many people ask uh should
I uh am I using the wrong blogging
platform because of which I'm not able
to escalate my AdSense earning is it
that maybe uh typ ad is in the right one
or is it that MSN space is in the right
one well uh that isn't uh that doesn't
hold true if your content is good you're
promoting it perfectly people are liking
your stuff they want to come back and
want to hear more from you the platform
doesn't really matter but still if you
do want to make sure that you are using
the best of the bestest platform uh
blogger and the
wordpress.com blogger which is Blogspot
and WordPress are the best ones are the
best two available platforms two most
popular platforms I would recommend
across so that's another thing so number
one get your get to know the stuff which
you are really passionate about number
two in the B from the basics point of
view make sure you're using the best
platform and these are the two ones I
would recommend but I'm not I'm not
telling you that the other ones are not
good they are absolutely but if you're
if you still have the chance to go ahead
and uh decide and you're starting fresh
then you can go out of any of these two
the second thing in order to go ahead
and uh make sure that you
are you're on the right path in terms of
making more money is to go ahead and
identify your audience get to know your
audience the demographics and the
psychographics and overall your content
post needs to be in line with what your
audience really wants to read about
whether you go ahead with the primary
research you talk to them over the phone
you talk to them over the email uh you
do the interactions uh oneon-one which
is a very expensive method but
ultimately you have to really know your
end audience if you know your end
audience and uh the likes and the
dislikes of them then uh and it is a
consistent consistent process you cannot
just go ahead and do it once and then
you sit and relax you have to take
feedback on continuous
uh on a continuous uh level you cannot
just uh take uh a feedback once and then
sit and relax it has to be an ongoing
process once you have identified your
audience the other best thing which we
specifically do for Google AdWords
campaigns and SEO search engine
optimization Campaign which are the two
most great uh digital marketing channels
uh we would it's best best to go ahead
and perform that thing over here as well
which we do for Google AdWords and SEO
that is called keyword research so there
are various tools which are available
across in the Internet space which helps
us to do keyword research keyword is
nothing but the search term which is
across into the search engines Google
AdSense prefer across those websites
which get across good amount of traffic
from search engines and specifically the
organic organic or the unpaid so we do
talk about all these things with what is
unpaid or organic stuff in our digital
marketing courses at simply learn and uh
we we learn across all that in detail
and that is something which is very much
Essential when it comes down to going
ahead and promoting your brand your blog
priting more money so doing the keyword
research and finding out what your end
audience is really looking at the most
which keywords are they typing in the
most in the search bar once you get to
know those then you go ahead and embed
those right set of keywords into your
content so that they match and
ultimately uh your the overall chances
of your content piece coming out the top
all the search results become higher and
as a result you get much more organic
traffic through the organic listings and
your AdSense earnings becomes much more
bigger because of the more traffic you
get another piece of caution is that uh
do not write about your product and
services this is one great piece of
caution do not be a salesperson who's
just writing about the features and
functionalities of your product and so
forth talk about something with your end
audience really it has to be informative
so that is one
don't excuse
me that is one piece of Z which is uh
which is a sort of a mistake that many
many bloggers do so make sure you do not
turn out to be a sales guy and rather be
an informative
person number H so all right so I would
not say it's a number two or number
three rather we spoken about three four
things which will help you a piece of
advice which will help you to get across
much more money Min more money with blog
or your website by having Google AdSense
on on them make sure the content which
you're uploading across that is a
different mix of post so look at any
great website which is getting good
amount of traffic which is well renowned
you would find different content with
different uh different mix Al together
having a news having a uh video having a
uh an Mage
stuff excuse me
guys or having some opinion about
something or the other right so that's
another piece of uh advice when comes
down to creating a cross content for
your blog the different kind of blog
post which needs to be there
uh it can be basic uh very rotine post
can be some thoughtful uh
stuff excuse me some funny and
entertaining post and so forth I'm so
sorry I'm not sure what happen having
some right so all these different kind
of
post will ultimately help the audience
to Great uh to read different kind of
stuff and break the monotony do not just
try to be a serious kind of a Blog which
is just uh talking about one single
thing again and again you have to really
understand from the audience point of
view and two experimentations also you
cannot be right always uh till so till
the time you do not try you won't get to
know the overall behavior of your end
audience make sure you have the Google
analytics uh attached to your website
and then you see the overall reaction
whenever you have come up with a new
post right how has the traffic really
gone up or down and so forth what has
been the reacts and so forth do look
into the overall timings and the overall
days on when you are posting uh some
content which day which particular
timing whether it's the morning hours or
the evening hours you get you're getting
across the maximum traffic and maximum
engagement another piece of information
another piece of advice is to go ahead
and write attractive post and also
comments so not just posting uh a blog
post is your
job it's also it's also better to go
ahead and interact with your audience
who are going coming ahead coming onto
your website or to your blog and then
posting into the comment section keep uh
make sure that you are interacting with
them replying to their queries and
comments on uh on regular intervals and
you're not delaying those responses and
so forth so that if this they feel they
are connected to the Blogger and and uh
the Blogger is concerned about the
reader now when it comes down to
creating content uh this is one obstacle
which many many great bloggers face
across any any sort of a blogger face
across which is they run out of ideas so
uh when you run out of ideas it's
absolutely reading which helps you to
get across much more ideas so you can
use it P certain tools which uh are
pretty renowned Google Reader is one of
most for the most most uh renowned and
and mine favorite too you can go ahead
and put in across certain keywords on
Google Reader and it'll keep inating you
about that particular piece of stuff
what all different content is getting
uploaded across on the internet using
that keyword so usage of Google uh uh
alerts Google uh so Google Alerts
primarily uh reading across more other
different websites news talking about
festivals and holidays and so for also
the best thing is to go and ask your
readers that's the best thing to go
ahead and do that when it comes down to
how to write the attractive post it all
starts with the heading and uh also make
sure that you have only one idea per
post do not go ahead and get confused uh
and make the audience also confused
about what you're trying to share across
so do not mix and match several things
in one post make sure you're using one
idea you're compan getting one idea per
post do list out the important points
use uh simple language
uh usage of bullet points adding media
uh uh content in different other uh
stuff whether it's a image whether it's
a video and so forth different uh pieces
of content and also if you
can have certain uh contest or any other
exciting stuff where you offering some
uh freebies or you're offering some
other stuff for your readers you are
trying to reward your readers for
participating and reading your
stuff right like I al already mentioned
it's
also uh good to go ahead and be
connected with your audience of the blog
comments that ultimately stay connected
with your audience and that is something
which will make them uh come back and
ultimately it will result into much much
more traffic on your website right so uh
make sure you are thanking you're
congratulating your and your your people
who are commenting and so
forth the other piece of advice is to be
consistent right with whatever you're
typing across you need to be uh with a
Blog many bloggers what they really do
they are very eager in terms of uh going
ahead
and running this Marathon but many of
them fail Mis in the beginning they they
lose heart and so forth so make
sure make sure you do that across
on level stick to a publishing schedule
so whatever schedule you have in place
in the initial uh when you are coming up
with so it has to be monthly calendars
which I advise to all my trainings when
it comes down to Content publishing and
content scheduling it has to be done in
one month in advance at least right
stick to your calendar do not fail in
terms of putting across content on time
and so forth make sure you're using
creativity and uh content is something
which is the best asset which will help
you to get across more traffic along
with coupled along with the marketing
skill sets the digital marketing skill
sets and so forth right when both of
them get kind of collaborated together
you you are bound to get relevant
traffic repeated traffic repeated
visitors and ultimately that is the key
to get a Ross much much more money with
uh whatever content you're putting
across and the last thing which I would
say is to go ahead and share it share it
promote it and Market use the marketing
skill sets right the overall digital
marketing skill sets I would talk about
sharing is one of the key factors so let
everybody know about what all you have
uh uploaded across uh something which is
within your boundaries something which
is more accessible for you and uh it's
primar the social media sites which are
the popular ones being the Twitter
Facebook and so forth right now talking
about the website quality and AdSense we
uh make sure that whenever you applying
in for Google
AdSense you have the top level domain of
yours right something like dubdub dub.
example.com is owned by you rather than
you have content on dub dub. example.com
my/ mysite right so the top level domain
should be with you and and uh your
domain so this is these are
some uh
extra uh things which one should uh
really gohe and put in across for making
sure the chances of their application
approval is much more with Google
AdSense and so forth plus make sure that
your domain should have been registered
and active the there should have been
content on your website which is at
least 6 months old right and you should
provide absolutely correct piece of
information when with when you are
applying in for Google AdSense when your
AdSense account is being approved
another piece of information which I
want to give you make sure that at least
$10 is being earned across in six months
otherwise Google AdSense go goes ahead
and disapproves your entire account so
minimum $10 by in six months your
website should contain substantial or
content and you should comply with all
the other Google AdSense policies and so
forth so there are small little policies
which can
really uh disapprove your stuff right
your entire application and so forth
what else so we've spoken quite a lot
about what to blog what not to blog what
to do whether to share it whether to get
across content which is informative and
so forth right what else do we really
want to talk about well there are
various things which makes a Google
AdSense account approved in certain
Google AdSense account disapproved if
you have unique content you have Unique
Images you you should
apply at least with 20 post being there
on your blog right do not make do not go
ahead and apply for AdSense account if
you have lesser content on your website
20 is a bpark figure we can talk about
few people say it has to be at least 50
post and so forth content which is at
least more than 6 months old and it
should have gener information for the
users the various reasons which makes a
Google AdSense application to be
disapproved
are a applications of websites which
does which only have got images or
watermarked images have got content
which is duplicate or copied across from
somewhere else or a defamed blog or a
website or have got negative content and
so forth all
right now what are the different dis
what are the disadvantages of Google
AdSense guys well I would't call them
disadvantages uh to be uh I mean to be
the right word for it I would say
something which uh few bloggers actually
call it right few bloggers certain
section of the society says that uh
Google AdSense is not uh meant is not
friendly for the Publishers why do they
say that they fail that they they say
that they go ahead and disable your
account if you haven't really earned $10
in 6 months and uh plus it's it's a
disadvantage thing for those who go
ahead and click onto their advertisement
by themselves right which is absolutely
a strict no it's another piece of
information I would say is whenever your
Google AdSense account is approved do
not go ahead and tell it to the world
that your Google AdSense account is
approved this is one one rule of some uh
somebody can go ahead and click onto
your onto the
U ads which are there on your website
and and it and it has happened so it's
one uh piece of advice I would say plus
the kind of content which you're
uploading across make sure that it has
to be unique and uh again it becomes a
disadvantage thing for those who are not
good with content creators right who
just want to go ahead and copy content
so this is for those right this piece of
stuff now when it comes down to
promotion I've already spoken about the
the right promotion back takes is
something along with unique content that
will help you to upscale your uh
earnings right the revenue which you're
going to get across from Google AdSense
so whether you go ahead and get across
traffic with the help of social media
marketing or email marketing and or
through commenting on different blocks
by networking across and so forth plus
with search engine optimization and so
forth right when we talk about certain
tips for more
content uh the Google AdSense doesn't
really look at your spelling mistakes
and so forth Google AdSense doesn't
really uh you know uh care about that
it's just a myth that Google AdSense has
disapproved because of a spelling
mistake and so forth the but it doesn't
mean that you're going to go ahead and
do spelling mistakes right make sure you
do not do that in order to attract users
uh you have to have content which is
useful unique and uh value driven right
content which is copied I'm saying that
again is a strict no it's a strict no
readers are always looking for Content
that they haven't really experienced
they haven't really seen they haven't
really heard they haven't really read at
any other platform that's the first
platform they have come up across some
more tips for Content pieces make sure
that content which you're writing across
should be at least for 520 to 550 words
uh another school of thought many many
people say that if you have much much
more written content which is up to
2,000 words that'll help you they'll
help you to get across uh better search
engine rankings but another school of
thought says uh much lendy content is uh
is going to put off the end Target user
so I would say it differs from s uh
audience to audience situation to
situation you have to really understand
what sort of audience are you targeting
if you have a very serious brand
probably 2,000 words is a is absolutely
a yes if you
have uh bit of a b2c brand which is not
on the strict side I mean you can go
ahead and just ride across uh 400 500
wordss content and that is it is
absolutely good to go uh you can stick
to that also if you have uh some
information about HTML and so forth uh
that can really help you uh plus make
sure that you're consistent you're
devoting at least two to four or three
hours a day on writing across content
pieces onto your blog and other on other
blog sites com their blog post
networking so that people know you and
that has to be unique do not go ahead
and copy that across re so I recommend
write contents at your convenient place
so this is another thing if you are if
you think the more ideation comes across
when you're sitting in your garden area
or at a seashore and so forth that that
helps your mind to relax and get across
uh some UniQue Ideas uh make sure you go
ahead and pin down those ideas and put
them across on your blog this these are
some very Basics and I you would say uh
uh nothing extraordinary which I'm
talking about when it comes down to
getting those ideas but these are few
things which people uh which are very
basic but still they don't do it when it
comes down to putting across content and
creating content so write for the
audience and not for making money if you
are creating content with with this
thought in mind that you want much more
AdSense earning then ultimately you
won't be able to get that trust me make
sure that you have this thought into
your mind that you are creating content
for pleasing your end audience for
giving them what they want the things
will fall into place automatically and
the the revenue which you're going to
get across from msense will ultimately
go up but you need to have patience for
that it's not a a quick turnaround thing
it's not an overnight kind of a thing
which will happen right so give
meaningful and postive information for
the leaders one of the most common
mistakes having too many link on a
single post is a simple no right and
having similar expression of words even
though the contents are unique multiple
domain contains in single post is also
absolutely enough having much more post
with similar expression of words and too
much design with a lot of different
coloring and so forth irregular
arrangement of content and so forth is
absolutely is is a no a strict no if you
talk about the various advantages of
Google AdSense what do really help with
earnings are high when you compare it
across with other different uh networks
so Google AdSense has got various other
networks Google AdSense is the most
premier and most highly paid I mean it
pays you much more than the other uh
networks which are there the payment
deliveries are accurate fast they're not
there's no uh I mean we haven't really
heard of any stories where they have
missed out on something and so forth
Google plus there are no errors Google
LS for Google looks for much more
quality unique content uh but not thiss
this uh so Google AdSense has this
particular which advantage right so
Google AdSense looks for much more
quality and ads the overall ads which
are being reflected across uh are they
are in conjunction with what the content
is and so forth the corporate ads much
more repetive now who can earn more so
writers who Express their feelings I've
already spoken about that in their own
way the in the way of content uh what
they're putting across each post they
write across have to be totally unique
different what they're trying to express
to their readers and that should uh that
should be uh found to be much more
interesting so the readers should found
that content to be interesting there is
uh another way of going ahead and
getting across much more uh traffic on
your website through a different Source
through different marketing pieces But
ultimately this the most crucial thing
if you are having content which is
perfectly right you can go ahead and get
that working for you now what are the
skills required for blogging if you say
that not very much technical skills are
needed right uh it's Bas if you have
basic knowledge of HTML which is used
across for search engine optimization it
can be an added Advantage if you do not
have knowledge of HTML and so forth that
is also okay that is absolutely also
okay but it's it's an added Advantage so
Google never looks for complicated code
it's always look for Unique content in
HTML readers are also looking for much
more information information and not
your code not not your design and so
forth right so creative writing skill
sets uh choose across the best uh place
where you can go ahead and create your
blog app whether it's a WordPress or
blog spot having basing HTML knowledge
social media social networking skills
I would say entirely totally digital
marketing skill sets coupled along with
great piece of content which you are
passionate about are the two major
things the two major so I've told you
plenty of things but if you go ahead and
ask me uh one single thing which
will overall summarize everything I
would say it's
uh putting across content which you're
passionate about and your readers like
it coupled with digital marketing skill
sets which includes everything whether
it's social media networking search
engine optimization getting traffic with
uh email marketing getting traffic with
the help of inbound marketing conversion
optimization getting traffic with the
help of uh display ads and so forth if
you want to go with the paid
advertisement social media uh using
across all the platforms whether it's
Facebook Twitter LinkedIn and so forth
and so on so these are the skill sets
which are required a cross for blogging
and as a professional career if you talk
about
uh you can also if you want to grow that
big you don't want to do it across just
as an alone kind of a thing you want to
move that to a bigger level you can
build your organization and hire across
great content writers digital marketers
HTML programmers who can do that job for
you and uh you can build up many more
properties many more blogs like this and
connect across to your single Google
AdSense account right and you can learn
earn out of it that can be coupled
across with affiliate marketing and so
forth I we not talking more about
affiliate marketing but uh if you want
to go ahead and make multiplier earnings
then
uh I mean you being a professional
blogger you being uh I mean you can
replicate that entire stuff by hiring
more people underneath you if you'll see
more websites who are minting more money
uh there are certain people who are just
onean Army right there are there are
certain people who are onean army and
minting a lot of money through asense
but in uh in a
very possible manner on a ground level
if I talk about you want to go ahead and
multiply that you need to have a team
underneath you who comprises of great
content writers great uh HTML
programmers who can make changes to the
websites and blogs and so forth and
great digital marketers who can help in
getting much more traffic onto your
website which you're using for
publishing content and so forth
ultimately when all this gets coupled up
and you're doing things in the uh best
possible way with the help of your team
you're adding on you're getting across
much more Revenue out of all
this right so that's what all I had to
talk about like I rightly said I'm going
to be taking plus 50 minutes and that's
what I've done and uh I think I'm going
to hand it over to chip who's going to
talk more of our uh the other
stuff
fantastic I'm gonna mute you real quick
there so that I don't get uh hear myself
back there in the speakers but uh thank
you so much great stuff I'm really
looking forward to looping back around
and uh going ahead and uh doing the Q&A
we're going to go through uh the the
questions here uh starting from the top
we have a hard stop at the half hour
hour so we've got about eight minutes to
get through as many as we possibly can
uh Harish has asked um I'm using a
website that uh I built out last year
that was in WordPress and I have now
transferred to
Magento which I believe is an e-commerce
platform and uh Harish is asking if
Google AdSense uh works well with
Magento absolutely so uh the answer to
your question in one single word is yes
uh Google AdSense doesn't really differ
uh you know doesn't look into the CMS
functionality which you're using whether
you're using Wordpress or Magento or
zumla uh the main thing which Google I
did mentioned again and again it's the
quality content and uh absolutely right
and the right it's a Content so CMS is
something which is uh not a
consideration for Google AdSense it's
the answer is yes it will work it works
well terrific
um I uh did a a real quick search too
and I found a page on the Magento site
uh with documentation on how to
integrate AdWords into your Magento
store so I'm going to go ahead and share
that link into the chat module folks so
uh uh Harish if you want to take a look
at that you can click through and find
more information Devon is asking uh
pardon me can we as the publisher allow
advertisers from other networks besides
Google uh and AdSense and and would
Google will reduce our rating because
we're using other uh advertising
Platforms in addition to AdSense and
negatively impact our
traffic absolutely so uh that's a great
question and I've heard this question
many time so if you're using multiple ad
networks onto your website uh go there
are fair higher number of chances that
Google can go ahead and ban and uh stop
you stop you from their from from your
existing AdSense account so it's
advisable to use only one single piece
of AD Network and do not mix and match
the other on so there are plenty of them
which are available so I know many
people do that across
for just because they're uh you know
they want to make more money not from
Google AdSense but from the other
networks also and there are plenty of
sites which are available they are able
to do that uh just because they're
pretty old and uh they have used certain
I would say black hat techniques right
if you go if you want to do it the most
legal way and if you read the policies
which Google AdSense says they say do
not use any other AD Network along with
us so the answer is yes it does affect
negatively that is
correct Perfect all I appreciate that
Insight um Deon I hope that was helpful
to you uh let's see um now pratish is
asking uh how and and you touched on
this a little bit about making sure that
uh you understand your audience and
you've done some research and and you
understand who they are and what they're
looking for um but uh do you have he's
asking how can I really ensure that my
correct audience uh is being targeted uh
so I I don't know if you can put any
finer of a point or uh perhaps direct us
to some additional resources to help
prti and the others understand uh the
best way to make sure that they're
targeting the Right
audience absolutely so this is primar in
the behavior segment uh the behavior
section which you get across into the
Google analytics so for that you got to
be having a good fair amount of
knowledge about Google analytics so you
got to educate yourself onto how do you
really uh work into the smaller section
of Google adct and once you integrate
that perfectly then that gives you
information onto where exactly is the
traffic coming in from what is the age
group as well so that's not precise with
Google antics says so but still you get
a fair amount of idea the kind of
content uh I mean the kind of interest
level they have the the AG the gender
and so forth so the behavioral so you
get the geographic uh demographic all
those segmentation Google analytics in
in
totality excellent thank
you that's great uh deanon has a
follow-up question here once once ad uh
AdSense is approved to our
website
uh why shouldn't we tell our circle of
people about our AdSense
approval all right so uh that is
something which Google adson doesn't say
that but that is something which uh uh
it's it's a sort of a advice which
various bloggers do that bloggers say
that it's not it's not a good practice
to share that across with others if
somebody doesn't want you to earn money
me you know if you're looking at the
other way they can go ahead and start
clicking onto your ads and that's called
click bombing so you have to really make
sure that uh uh there's nobody who's
doing click bombing onto your
advertisements if that happens across
then Google AdSense if it's a fairly new
account that can get onto review and
there are fair chances that it can get
disapproved so just to be on the safer
size I see so yeah so the concern is
that you tell your friends hey I've got
Google AdSense and they think they're
doing you a favor by running to your
site and clicking on ads to help you
earn money Google's going to see that as
as an abuse of the
system absolutely absolutely so your
friends wanted to help you but
ultimately that RNs the other way gotcha
all right let's see uh we have uh
another question from prti what if
Google Places ads of our competitors on
our website is there a way for us to
filter the ads uh or uh maybe uh uh
block certain URLs uh ads from appearing
on our
website absolutely that is so that's a
very good question so uh every every
publisher does that so Publishers who do
not want their competitors to show
across their advertisements when uh on
on their website so within the AdSense
dashboard uh there is a feature of
blocking URLs so you can specify
specific URLs of your competitors and
there's another feature where you can
block websites from a certain industry
as well so if I mention that no website
from the fashion industry uh should be
allowed to Showcase that Banner ad onto
my website I can block uh industry
related websites and I can block
specific uh websites so both of them are
there
absolutely perfect uh that's it I think
we've answered virtually every question
uh I hope so and um we do have our uh
we're up against the hard stop here at
the half hour we've got another webinar
that's scheduled to start pretty soon
and we have to get off of uh of go to
webinars uh uh uh system here so uh that
said I have shared a few links into the
chat module folks take a quick look at
that click on any of them that you need
to and get them opened up in your
browser uh before we have to go um I've
uh given you some links to uh Google's
terms of service that uh Nick shared
earlier I've also given you some links
to some simply learn courses regarding
digital marketing and WordPress training
uh and uh a few other things and of
course a link to the upcoming webinars
from Simply learn so you can go and uh
take a look at the uh resources we have
available the Articles and the webinars
that are organized by specialty and uh
please feel free to join future webinars
with us as well we'd love to have you
all on board I wish we had more time to
keep keep talking I in particular love
this subject uh uh the subject of
building community building a an
audience uh and building out your uh
your blogging presence Nick so thank you
so much for sharing your insights it's
really been fun hanging out here with
you